if a flower doesn't Bloom do you blame
the flower or do you blame its
environment right so imagine like if
this plant didn't Bloom are you going to
like blame the plant and Chuck the plant
are you going to check the soil are you
going to check the light are you gonna
check the air around it the humidity
because that's the reason why the plant
grows right so we are that flower right
but if we're not growing or we're not
sprouting or blooming the right way what
is your environment who are you talking
to what Instagrams are you scrolling
what things are you filled with in your
feed what's your mind constantly talking
about even if it's about your body